[Musica]
bella 20 ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo a chi
è adesso allegati pomeriggio alle tre
veda tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono favi no non ci credo non ci
credo
chi è entra
cioè due ore per aprire quella porta
l'ha capito adesso mi spieghi cosa fai a
casa mia
alle 15 è un quarto o una cosa in tour
mentre io registro fine che è
importantissima perché stai facendo
sto registrando in questo momento va bè
videogiochi ea proporre videogiochi
allora ho scoperto questa app di poste
italiane pazzesca che che aiuta a
salvare gli animali ci sono le 15 da
allora gli amici di babbo natale è solo
sapere di maio salvare e può essere i
soldi del film tribuno la tigre quello
che mi guarda giocare inizia la missione
votarla comando se non lo faccio con cai
allora faceva nel secondo secondo fatti
vedere perché non evitare le buste di
plastica i petrolio registrare il
gameplay è il viaggio di listare inferno
avere di star e interniamo nepi saremo
per il bayern i due reti che oggi la
baita
vuoi essere inflitte band di flip vuoi
giocare a qualcosa come fare una cosa un
po più seria sicura facciamo così tu
guardi qui ma cosa i 321 fecisti e
adesso si gioca ma fammi cosa hai
combinato dove sono finite aiutami
tranquilla sapri ti ho portato a giocare
esattamente dove volevi tu ti trovi in
questo preciso momento all'oasi del web
e di vanzago ti ho portato io sì ma non
riesco a muovermi non riesci a muoverti
ne sei sicuro o cosa mi succede ai
presenti videogiochi no tu sei mio
personaggio adesso c'è city voglio far
fare una giravolta tu la fai ti faccio
fare la ruota si si non capitolare già
capito assicura e allora giuliano ok
[Musica]
come hai fatto a farmi vestire da
elefante pare che stai veramente bene
secondo me comunque comunque tu in
questo momento devi arrivare ad un oasi
però però nel boschetto che c'è dietro
di te che devi attraversare per arrivare
all'oasi ci sono le provviste che sono
nascosti in dei sacchi tu nel mentre che
vai all'osi raccoglie le provviste ai
tre vite a disposizione
attenzione perché nei sacchi non ci sono
solo provviste ci sono anche altre
sorpresine quindi attenzione a prendere
i sacchi giusti
intanto ti guido io che attenta niente
non era via sani guidi to 3 2 1 iniziamo
ma mi stai muovendo tumori certo che ti
sto muovendo come sempre ma intanto io
ho sbagliato io prendo atti come la mano
quei comandi e perso già una vita e
attenzione mi sento alle divisioni a
sinistra
ok quale ci voce dentro scelgo questa
qui ho vinto io lori stavolta è il primo
ce l'ho fatta adesso sinistra ma perché
mi fai correre cammino g10 di sto
provando un po tutti i comandi quindi
corri e cammina occupati un po tutto
questo qua di destra e spera per te che
sia della frutta
vediamo
no no qui ci sono i caprini non aprì
abbiamo preso due vite tale rimanga ti
rimane solo una un'atene rimane
sì l'ho visto stai tranquillo che
indossava yara sinistra grazie prego o
meno male che mi ascolto andiamo a farci
portare bene essere sincronizzati grazie
sei riuscita faranno da fare bene no di
corsa che sono spariti correre se plico
di cose va bene ok occhio occhio perché
hai solo una vita non sbagliare il
saviano sbagliare sakai una vita sola
secondo te lo vedi il mio sorrisino
eccolo qui e quindi ho vinto winton
vinto vinto
abbiamo però c'è una cosa nuova la mia
devi dire mesi abbiamo giocato calcifica
sterline dai gita andiamo avanti
scommetto che questa volta sono un
pinguino vero cosa mi devi far fare ci
sono dei pinguini sono intrappolati in
delle reti perché sono fratelli 2 2 a 2
non uno solo due ha dunque è di
riportare sul live perché vedi lì in
fondo dietro di tempo abbiamo solo 90
secondi quindi muoviamoci lag e due alla
volta i due alla volta esattamente ma
anche se resta prenderne di più
no se riesce a premere di più ne
prendiamo della volta sono variati che
ha due perché ti ho detto che so
fratelli devi tornare indietro le emessi
storno dai sogni lo so devi fare meglio
ma almeno con accenti secoli poi per di
energia non posso più farti correre dopo
mila devo andare
senti decido io se ti comando io decido
io veloce
mamma mia quanto lenta che cosa non
funziona ha portato stanca cosa si sta
greco su un minuto sì ma rotolo che
faccio prima quando manca pochissimo
veloce 54
hai finito guarda manca veramente poco
giuro quando sono quasi forte adesso
andiamo andiamo ad ora non ho adesso
parlo io
andiamo dove di quello prossimo livello
e adesso che cosa faccio io qui visiterà
adesso sempre sei vestita la tigre
perché devi trovare il tuo cucciolo
molto molto easy per trovare il tuo
cucciolo di rientrare nel bosco e
superare alcune sfide
ok devi rispondere a delle domande cose
così di guido io vado lori hai detto che
questa è l'ultima è esatto questa è
l'ultima guarda in alto ci sono tre
carte
e tu per ogni carta adesso io ti dirò un
esemplare e tu mi dirai che carta
corrisponde sito rai allora il primo
animale caracal cane e gatto topo l'oeil
caracal sì però se tu in casa cioè solo
cani e gatti non è colpa mia
riconoscerlo il caricato quale è l'esser
ala due bravissimi ha sbagliato
allora provo con l'a1 che è la prima hai
portato a casa
andiamo alla prossima la seconda è la
lince la lince l'ho vista e allora per
forza la 2 brava stavolta è andata bene
l'ultima che mi devi dominare è la
pantera quale sarà mai di queste tre
visto che due lei già dette pantera lo
sanno tutti sono stata in africa non
vedrai
sì perché si scatena perché aveva
nominato stanno troppo brava bravissima
segui le indicazioni aveva tigli di la
propria riva andiamo devi semplicemente
indovinare i versi che faccio 321 un
animale col mal di pancia sì sì sì è un
animale con a di pancia il tema sacri ma
di prova ha mangiato malissimo che sta
arrivando
si chiamava quel prossimo pronta 3 2 1
ieri a cavallo e in cavallo proprio
quello meglio di così non potevo qua una
volta sistemato vicino dai guarda in
alto
segui la freccia davanti a te in questo
preciso momento vedi tre carte
una è una canna di bambù la seconda è
l'eucalipto e l'ultima è il salmone
io adesso ti dico chi mangia la prima e
tu mi dai la risposta quindi la prima è
una canna di bambù chi mangia la canna
di bambù lari io e te siamo stati nella
foresta di bambù insieme sì me lo
ricordo però mi devi dire l'animale non
mi devi ricordare cosa abbiamo fatto
panda ci credo che sparando hai trovato
il panda ma edizione è il giusto quindi
che però non vale lo meriti ma veniamo
alla seconda dai la seconda è
l'eucalipto chi mangia località non so
perché ne vorrei uno in camera fisco ala
regala ogni notte per favore no sapri
non ti regalo nessun quale ci stiamo
salvando cosa ti regalo terza carta il
salmone ti mangio salmone salmone è
facilissimo perché lo mangia sasha lo
mangia lo mangia sasha sì sì però non
c'è l'animale devi dirmi non chi lo
mangia che conosce i miei gattoni
l'animale quello che non c'è una cosa
che non conosci tu che non c'è in casa
che non è saggia che non sono i tuoi
amici
chi mangia il salmone ok l'orso tra loro
ai vinti 6.000 ogni 10 disposti dovuto
dare aiuto sono morte a segnar di cembra
ballo danza lo guarda implementi te lo
sei meritato anche se ce l'hai fatta
fatica perché dobbiamo dirlo è fatto
fatica e natale quindi sono più buono te
lo concedo hai superato la prova tv ma
gli animali cioè alla fine non sei
contento vivo gli animali e vero però
diciamo che un pochettino mi sono
divertito anche lui a vederti vestita da
pinguino e se ci credo mi ha anche fatto
fare una fatica altro che i giochi della
quali si sono più semplici
ovvio che sono più semplici sabrina sono
per bambini
ascolta sono due ore che devo dirti una
cosa posso adesso di quello che mi devi
dire di melo io ho ricevuto questa c'è
guarda che bella una letterina pure la
letterina ricevuto dove senti facciamo
così torna a qualche me la fai vedere
chi sei
sì ma toc toc dei farmi dire tu
finalmente sono tornati stata veramente
brava complimenti bravi singola mano
perché sei stato veramente brava su di
una cosa non è che potrei avere anche io
ma letterino questa citavo ma scusami
per te questa letterina no non è per me
che vorrei farlo avere ad una persona
speciale
facciamo così scrivete anche voi la
letterina a babbo natale perché fa buon
natale vi conosce un po anziano però sa
un po tutto di voi vi risponderà quindi
giocate con questa applicazione
divertitevi arrivate fino a livello
perché è poter salvare gli animali video
il mio dovrei parlare io nel video mio è
mio
paolo ii il canale dove c'è scritto quei
cali eguale g a vision bra e la ti parla
chi parla brava capito
parlo io sul mio canale parlo io
[Musica]